READY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE Ó STREET
BUILDING. I ASK ALL MEMBERS WHO
ARE LISTENING TO. PLEASE JOIN
US. IS GOING TO BE A SHORT
MEETING. HOPEFULLY WE HAVE TWO
BILLS. BUT BEFORE WE PROCEED,
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, ADAM, ASSISTANT RUBIO
PRESENT RUBIO PRESENT. NILO
HERE. NILO HERE. ALVARADO. GIL
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ. HERE
DODD. OKOBO PRESENT. WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM, AS STATED,
WE HAVE TWO BILLS. SO AGAIN,
HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE SHORT. AND
AGAIN, I'M ENCOURAGING ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO JOIN
US SO WE CAN, LEAVE QUICKLY,
FIRST UP, WE HAVE, I DON'T SEE
MR. RODRIGUEZ, SO WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME, ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
PACHECO, WHO WILL BE PRESENTING
BILL AB 2743. WELCOME
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. AND WHEN YOU'RE
READY, YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
SENATORS, I AM HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2743. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE STAFF
FOR THEIR EXTENSIVE FEEDBACK AND
TIME SPENT ON THIS BILL. AB 2743
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND PROVIDES AN APPROPRIATE
ADJUSTMENT IN FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS FOR PEER
TO PEER CAR SHARING PLATFORMS.
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
REFLECTS MONTHS OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION, AND GOOD
FAITH ATTEMPTS TO MITIGATE THEIR
CONCERNS AND PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CLARITY ON THE BILL'S INTENT,
WHICH IS TO SET FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS IN. 2025
TO 45,090 K FOR BODILY INJURY
AND 15 K FOR PROPERTY DAMAGE
INCREASED THREE TIMES THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LIMIT
FOR 2035 REQUIRE NEW ROBUST
CONSUMER DISCLOSURES AND CREATE
NEW PENALTY PROVISIONS. THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES THE SAVINGS CLAUSE
LANGUAGE REQUESTED BY THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA, AB 27 TO. I CAN'T
EVEN TALK. AB 2743 SEEKS TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
REGULATION AND GROWTH, ENSURING
THAT PEER TO PEER CAR SHARING
REMAINS VIABLE AND BENEFICIAL
FOR BOTH USERS AND PROVIDERS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2743 ARE LÀ RISA
CESPEDES ON BEHALF OF TURO AND
ANDREA DEVAULT ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET, WHEN YOU'RE READY, CAN
WE BRING THEM TO THE. WHEN
YOU'RE READY? YEAH, YOU CAN COME
INTO THE FRONT, YOU MAY BEGIN.
I'M GOING TO ALLOW UP TO FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE TO, TO
PRESENT. WELCOME, LADIES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU. CAN YOU HEAR
ME? YES. CAN YOU HEAR ME? OKAY.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
LARISSA CESPEDES HERE ON BEHALF
OF TURO, TURO IS A PEER TO PEER
CAR SHARING PLATFORM BASED IN
SAN FRANCISCO WITH OVER 300
EMPLOYEES HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WE
HAVE 19,000 HOSTS, MANY OF WHOM
ARE IN YOUR DISTRICT, WHO DO
RELY ON THE EXTRA INCOME THAT
THEY EARN FROM THEIR ABILITY TO
SHARE THEIR VEHICLE ON THIS
PLATFORM. FIRST, I WANT TO
EXPRESS SINCERE THANKS TO ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE BEEN
PART OF THE CONVERSATION FOR THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF, IN
PARTICULAR, THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND WHILE WE HAVE THE
INSURERS AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE
HAVEN'T ADDRESSED ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS CONCERNS, BUT WE DO
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE THIS DEALS
WITH AN IMMEDIATE CRISIS FOR THE
INDUSTRY, WITH THE INCREASE OF
THE LIMITS IN 2025 BECAUSE OF A
SENATOR DODD BILL PASSED BY THIS
COMMITTEE, A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO. AND THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES
A 2035 TRIGGER TO INCREASE OUR
FR LIMITS BACK TO THREE TIMES TO
ENSURE THAT WE WILL BE BACK AT
THE TABLE TO ADDRESS THE MANY OF
THE ISSUES, IN PARTICULAR THE
DATA THAT WE THINK NEEDS TO BE
COLLECTED IN ORDER TO INFORM A
2035 RATE. BUT AT ANY RATE, THIS
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR TURO
AND ALL OF THE HOSTS AND USERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. I WILL
KEEP MY REMARKS BRIEF. MY NAME
IS ANDREA DEVAUX. I'M
REPRESENTING TECHNET TECNA'S
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP INCLUDES
DYNAMIC AMERICAN BUSINESSES
RANGING FROM STARTUPS TO THE
MOST ICONIC COMPANIES ON THE
PLANET, AND REPRESENTS OVER 5
MILLION EMPLOYEES AND COUNTLESS
CUSTOMERS. WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2743, AND THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO FOR HER
WORK ON THIS POLICY IN THE BILL.
WE FULLY AGREE WITH THE
TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE REPRESENTING
TURO, AND JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT AB 2743 INCLUDES
ROBUST CUSTOMER NOTICES AND
PENALTY PROVISIONS, ENSURING
THAT CALIFORNIANS WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE CAR SHARING
SERVICES AND INNOVATIONS REMAIN
PROTECTED AND WELL INFORMED WHEN
DRIVING IN CALIFORNIA, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 2743 AND THANK YOU
. THANK YOU, NOW I WOULD GO TO
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. YOU MAY COME UP TO
THE PODIUM. THANK YOU, JAMIE
HUFF, ON THE BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS.
CATHERINE CHARLES, ON BEHALF OF
THE CHAMBER OF PROGRESS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER SUPPORT, I WILL NOW LIKE
TO INVITE THE LEAD OPPOSITION TO
JOIN US. JOIN US IN THE FRONT
HERE. THANK YOU. I'LL GIVE YOU
THE SAME COURTESY OF TWO FOUR
MINUTES. THANK YOU. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. NØ.
NOW IT'S ON. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
ROBERT HARRELL. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THIS
BILL. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK OUR, OUR LOGO
GOT MISSED IN THE SUBMISSION. SO
I UNDERSTAND IT'S BEEN
RESUBMITTED AND IS NOW
ACCURATELY REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THE CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE HERE, AND I SHOULD NOTE
THAT I HAD SPENT ALMOST A HALF A
DOZEN YEARS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AS A DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER, AND SO I'M NOT
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE WORKINGS OF
THE DEPARTMENT. THE PROBLEM HERE
IS WE SEE IT IS A DATA GAP
PROBLEM, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE IS KIND OF BEING
FORCED INTO AN ISSUE WHERE WHEN
YOU OPINE ON ON SUCH A MATTER,
YOU WANT TO HAVE GOOD DATA, THE
DODD BILL THAT THE SUPPORTERS
REFERENCED, WHICH WAS MANY,
MANY, MANY YEARS IN COMING, IT
WAS RIFE WITH DATA. SENATOR
DODD, WE REMEMBER WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE. CFC HISTORICALLY HAS
NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON FRT
LIMITS PER SE, BUT THE DATA IS
THE KEY HERE. AND I THINK THAT
THE KEY THING THAT WE THINK IS
MISSING IN THIS BILL IS THE DATA
ELEMENT. THIS DOESN'T NEED TO BE
SOLVED IN A BILL NECESSARILY.
JUST HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE DO A DATA CALL AND
THEIR DATA CALLS ARE NOT A
BINARY ON OFF SWITCH. IT'S NOT
JUST YOU DO A DATA CALL OR YOU
DON'T DO A DATA CALL. THERE ARE
MANY, MANY ITERATIONS IN BETWEEN
THAT CAN COVER A BROADER SCOPE,
A NARROWER SCOPE, OBVIOUSLY NOT
THE DEPARTMENT ANYMORE, BUT IT
STRIKES ME THAT THIS IS NOT THE
WIDEST DATA CALL KNOWN TO MAN,
AND IT CAN BE NARROWLY CRAFTED
IN SUCH A WAY SO THAT BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE ACTS, YOU HAVE THE
RELEVANT INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE AN INFORMED POLICY
DECISION. THAT'S THE HEART OF
IT. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS IT COMES
UP, BUT WE, WHILE WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS, WE WOULD WE WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR TO, REALLY TACKLE THAT
DATA ISSUE OR HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TACKLE
THAT DATA ISSUE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SIR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED?
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MY NAME IS CONNOR KELLY.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS IN
PERSONAL INJURY AND WRONGFUL
DEATH CASES. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
MULTIPLE CASES INVOLVING PEER TO
PEER CAR SHARING, WITH
DISASTROUS RESULTS, IN 2019, IN
2020, THERE WERE, ROUGHLY. 35 TO
40 FATALITIES ON SAN FRANCISCO
STREETS, YEAR WIDE. IN EACH OF
THOSE YEARS, THERE WAS ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE FATALITIES IN
BOTH OF THOSE YEARS INVOLVED A
DRIVER OPERATING A VEHICLE THAT
WAS PROCURED THROUGH THE PEER TO
PEER SERVICE, THERE WERE
COMMONALITIES THAT MAKE THIS
PARTICULAR ENTERPRISE,
CONCERNING FOR CONSUMERS, NOT
THAT ARE RENTING THE VEHICLES,
BUT THAT ARE ON THE, ON CITY
STREETS, LIKE WHERE I LIVE, SAN
FRANCISCO, VEHICLES THAT WERE
PERFORMANCE VEHICLES. THESE WERE
NOT SORT OF EVERYDAY, YOU KNOW,
TOYOTA COROLLA TYPE CARS. ONE
INVOLVED THE PORSCHE CAYENNE,
THE OTHER INVOLVED A
SUPERCHARGED TESLA GOING AT HIGH
SPEEDS ON CITY STREETS,
RESULTING IN FATALITIES TO OTHER
USERS OF THE ROADWAYS. THE
CURRENT SYSTEM AS IT'S SET UP
AND WAS PUT IN PLACE, WHICH
WHICH IS TRYING TO BE CHANGED,
INVOLVES A SYSTEM WHERE THE
MINIMUM LIMITS ARE THREE X.
WHAT, PEOPLE WHO ARE OPERATING
THEIR OWN CAR REQUIRE THAT IS A
SMALL, SMALL PRICE TO PUT ON THE
COMPANIES WHO ARE OPERATING
THESE BUSINESSES AND HAVE
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR VALUATIONS
AS THEY TRY TO GO PUBLIC, SO
THAT CONSUMERS WHO ARE ON THE
ROADWAYS AND ARE HURT, INJURED
OR KILLED BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
PROCURE PERFORMANCE, HIGH SPEED
VEHICLES THROUGH THESE PLATFORMS
, ARE PROTECTED TO SOME DEGREE
FROM THE DISASTROUS RESULTS THAT
CAN OCCUR IN THESE TYPES OF
CASES AND CðC HAS BEEN MORE THAN
, HOSPITABLE IN TRYING TO OFFER
AMENDMENTS, WE'VE OFFERED WE'VE
OFFERED TO AGREE AND NOT OPPOSE
A REDUCTION OF THE LIMITS TO TWO
TIMES, WHICH IS MORE THAN
REASONABLE. STILL NOT ENOUGH,
GIVEN THE TYPE OF HARMS THAT
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND ON
CITY STREETS, BUT THAT HAS BEEN
REJECTED AND WITHOUT FURTHER
AMENDMENT. AND WITHOUT FURTHER
DATA, WHICH, AGAIN, THESE
COMPANIES WHO ARE PUSHING FOR
THIS BILL POSSESS ABOUT NUMBERS
OF ACCIDENTS, SEVERITY OF
ACCIDENTS, NUMBERS OF CLAIMS
THAT IT'S ALL DATA WHICH IS IN
THE POSSESSION OF THE COMPANIES
THAT ARE PUSHING THIS BILL
FORWARD. WITHOUT FURTHER DATA, I
DON'T SEE HOW, THIS COMMITTEE
CAN DECIDE DIED THAT THE
PROPOSED ONE X LIMITS ARE
APPROPRIATE, THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE OF THREE X.
THERE'S A CHANGE THAT'S BEING
SOUGHT AND THERE'S REALLY BEEN
NO DATA OR EXPLANATION
JUSTIFYING THAT CHANGE. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS,
YOU KNOW, BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE, BUT I THINK THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD KNOW THAT
INFORMATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, NOW, I BEFORE
QUESTIONS, I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. AND
HERE IN THIS ROOM, YOU MAY COME
UP TO THE PODIUM. OKAY. SEEING
NONE, I'LL BRING IT BACK NOW TO
THE MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS? ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS? MR.
CORTEZ, I DON'T HAVE I DON'T
HAVE QUESTIONS ON IT. THIS IS
THE BILL ITSELF IS A CLOSE CALL,
IF IT'S APPROPRIATE AT THIS
TIME, I WOULD JUST INDICATE
THAT, I'M GOING TO FALL ON THE
SIDE OF SUPPORTING IT, BECAUSE
I. MAYBE THIS IS FROM HAVING
BEEN AN AUTHOR JUST LONG ENOUGH
TO REALIZE THAT I THINK THE
WHILE WHILE THESE ISSUES ARE
VERY MUCH LINKED IN REAL LIFE,
THEY MAY JUST NEED TO BE DEALT
WITH IN SEPARATE VEHICLES AND
SEPARATE BILLS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THE DATA ISSUE IS HAS
OBVIOUSLY PROVEN TO BE JUST AN
ENORMOUS ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED WITH ITS OWN DEEP DIVE
AND ITS OWN, DEBATE THAT
PROBABLY NEEDS TO WORK ITS WAY
INDIVIDUALLY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THAT ISN'T, I
JUST WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
IT'S NOT THAT I'M DISMISSIVE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON THERE, I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. IT'S
CRITICAL, AND IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. BUT WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING PRETTY LATE IN THE
SESSION TO WORK IT OUT, I HOPE.
I WOULD HOPE IT COULD BE WORKED
OUT IF THE PARTIES COULD
CONTINUE TO TALK SOMEHOW. BUT IN
THE ABSENCE OF THAT, I'D HATE TO
LOSE WHAT WE DO HAVE AT THIS
POINT, YOU KNOW, AND AS I SAID,
HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY COMES BACK
AND, AND DOES SOME MORE WORK IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DODD. YOU HAD SOME
COMMENTS. YEAH. JUST TO BE
BRIEF, I CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
I, YOU KNOW, WE'D RATHER WE'D
PREFER THAT THERE BE NO DEATHS.
RIGHT ON OUR CITY STREETS. YEAH,
I'M NOT SURE THAT ONE ACCIDENT
AT, YOU KNOW, OUT OF 50 IN THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN A YEAR
OR SOMETHING THAT RISES TO THE
LEVEL OF THE KIND OF CONCERN
YOU'RE GETTING ON THIS. BUT THAT
SAID, IF THAT'S A POLICY FOR
DOWN THE LINE, I'M NOT I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT. SO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU, MR. DODD. ANYBODY
ELSE, SENATOR ALVARADO GIL.
THANK YOU. OH, I'M SORRY YOU
SAID MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU, I
WANT TO JUST MAKE A REALLY BRIEF
COMMENTS, BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
ANY CONSUMER WALKING AWAY
THINKING THAT WE'RE NOT FOCUSED
ON CONSUMERS AND THAT WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT CONSUMERS, AND I SO I
DO WANT A LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN
EXPLANATION HERE. AND I DID HEAR
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT WITH A FATALITY WITH
HIGH SPEED IN A CITY STREET. BUT
I MEAN, AS MR. DODD STATED, I
THINK THIS HAPPENS JUST
GENERALLY WE HAVE A RESPONSIBLE
DRIVERS, WHETHER IT'S YOUR CAR
OR SOMEONE ELSE'S CAR. IT JUST
BOILS DOWN TO THAT ONE DRIVER.
SO BECAUSE I HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DATA, JUST AS WELL AS YOU
DID, AND SO I JUST WANT TO PROBE
A LITTLE BIT MORE, IF I MAY,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT TIME TO GO DEEP INTO
THE DATA, BUT THERE ARE
STRUCTURAL ISSUES OR RATHER
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES IN
OBTAINING THAT DATA. THAT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE A LOT MORE
CONVERSATION. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES? SO AGAIN, I WANT
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND WHY RIGHT
NOW IN THIS MOMENT IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE. ABSOLUTELY. MADAM
CHAIR, I THINK MR. KELLY AND MR.
HALL BROUGHT UP SOME
INTERESTING, YOU KNOW, GOOD
POINTS. ONE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE COULD DO A DATA CALL.
I THINK IF WE INCLUDED THAT DATA
CALL IN THIS BILL, WE WOULD IN
FACT GARNER SOME OPPOSITION. AND
THERE'S SOME REASONS TO THAT.
ONE, THAT DATA IS NOT CURRENTLY
BEING COLLECTED. SO WHEN YOU ARE
IN AN ACCIDENT AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR I KNOW THERE ARE SOME
INSURERS THAT WILL PROBABLY
EXPLAIN THIS BETTER THAN I WILL,
BUT I'LL JUST EXPLAIN WHAT THEY
TOLD ME, WHICH IS WHEN THEY'RE
WHEN YOU'RE IN AN ACCIDENT AND
YOU'RE DRIVING SOMEONE ELSE'S
VEHICLE, THERE'S NO DESIGNATION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE
DRIVING YOUR MOTHER'S VEHICLE, A
RENTAL CAR OR A TURO, A CAR YOU
SECURED THROUGH TURO. SO IT'S
JUST GENERAL DATA ABOUT OTHER
CARS BEING DRIVEN, NOT TO THE
GRANULAR DATA ABOUT PEER TO
PEER. SO WE NEED TO WORK ON
THAT. ALSO, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER MAJOR
ISSUES THAT ARE OCCUPYING
INSURERS RIGHT NOW. AND THE
DEPARTMENT. AND SO I THINK WE
NEED SOME TIME TO ALLOW FOR THEM
TO FOCUS ON VERY CRITICAL ISSUES
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. NOT
THAT THIS ISN'T ONE OF THEM, BUT
VERY CRITICAL ISSUES. SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE SOME MORE
TIME TO DO THAT. AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE THAT 2035 FIGURE IN
THERE, BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO OPERATE AFTER
2035 IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT
FIXED. AND SO THAT'S GOING TO
ENCOURAGE US TO COME BACK TO THE
TABLE. WHAT YOU HAVE IS A IS A
BILL THAT WAS CAREFULLY CRAFTED
BY SOME GREAT WORK BY. I FORGOT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE OTHER HOUSE TO TRY AND
STRIKE THAT BALANCE OF HAVING
THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT WE
ALL WANT AND DESIRE, BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE GREAT MOBILITY OPTIONS. AND
THE OPTION FOR THESE HOSTS TO
CONTINUE EARNING INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
. AND I KNOW JUST BASED ON WHAT
THE AUTHOR STATED, AND I BELIEVE
YOU REITERATED, THERE HAVE BEEN
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS IN TRYING TO
RESOLVE THIS AND BY EVIDENCE
THAT, HEART OPPOSITION IS NOW
SORT OF SOFT OPPOSITION, UNLESS
ANYBODY DISAGREES HERE. RIGHT.
SO IT JUST SPEAKS TO THE FACT
THAT YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
BILL. SO I APPRECIATE IT. AND
AGAIN, BASED ON THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD, YOU
KNOW, IT'S JUST NOT EASY TO GET
TO THIS POINT. AND AT THIS
POINT, EITHER YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH WHAT YOU HAVE OR THE BILL
IS GOING TO DIE. SO I AGREE WITH
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES ON ON MY
RIGHT THAT AT THIS POINT, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK DOWN THE LINE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE TRIGGER, A
2035 TRIGGER, THAT MEANS IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S JUST GOING
TO DISAPPEAR. IT'LL FORCE
EVERYONE BACK AT THE TABLE IN
THE PROCESS TO GET TO A 20, 35.
AGREEMENT, IF YOU WILL. SO WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO THE AUTHOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL, CONVERSATIONS
HAVE BEEN HAD. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE HAVING CONVERSATIONS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK, AND
DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS, BUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR HERE, PAUL,
WHO'S HERE ALSO, FOR ALL OF HER
HARD WORK AS WELL, BECAUSE
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
HELD AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? Þ? I THINK IT WAS
ALVARADO GILL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHILE ITEM TWO AB 2743 BY
PACHECO. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. RUBIO I
RUBIO I NILO I NILO I ALVARADO
GIL I ALVARADO GIL I CABALLERO
CORTEZ CORTEZ I DODD DODD I
OKOBO OKOBO I. THE MEASURE IS 6
TO 1. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE.
WHAT IS IT? 6 TO 0. 6 TO 0. MY
APOLOGIES. AND IT WILL BE ON
CALL FOR THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE
ABSENT. WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER
TO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ,
WHO I SEE IN THE AUDIENCE WILL
BE PRESENTING AB 1505. I INVITE
THOSE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT TO
JOIN US UP HERE, AS WELL AS
THOSE OPPOSING THE BILL.
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ, WHEN YOU'RE READY,
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
AB 1505 AB 1505 WOULD ESTABLISH
A NARROW EXPANSION OF CLOSED
SESSION AUTHORITY UNDER THE
BAGLEY-KEENE OPEN MEETING ACT TO
ALLOW THE GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY
TO MEET IN CLOSED SESSION WHEN
DISCUSSING COMPETITIVE INSURANCE
STRATEGIES, THE BAGLEY-KEENE
OPEN MEETING ACT REQUIRES
MEETINGS OF STATE BODIES TO BE
AGENDIZE AND MADE OPEN AND
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC. THIS
IS GENERALLY GOOD PRACTICE FOR
TRANSPARENCY, BUT IT ALSO CAN
LEAD TO HINDER THE WORK OF THE
STATE BODY. LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY, CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OBTAINING AND
MANAGING EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE
POLICIES FOR ITS PARTICIPATE.
HOMEOWNER INSURANCE COMPANIES,
INSURANCE AND REINSURANCE
MARKETS ARE COMPETITIVE AND
EXPENSIVE, AND IF CEA S
GOVERNING BOARD DISCUSSES
NEGOTIATION STRATEGIES IN PUBLIC
, THEY RISK JEOPARDIZING THEIR
ABILITY TO SECURE FAIR, LOW
RATES FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS. AB
1505 IS MODELED AFTER SIMILAR
EXEMPTIONS PROVIDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT CEA CAN DISCUSS
REINSURANCE NEGOTIATIONS IN
PRIVATE, WHILE STILL PROVIDING
FOR GOVERNMENTAL TRANSPARENCY,
BY REQUIRING NOTICE OF WHAT
GENERALLY WILL BE DISCUSSED IN
CLOSED SESSION AND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. ARE TOM WELCH, CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY, AND SUZIE HERNANDEZ,
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY,
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
WELCOME BOTH OF YOU. YOU HAVE UP
TO FOUR MINUTES IF YOU CHOOSE TO
USE THEM. WE HOPE YOU DON'T. BUT
BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE HAPPY
TO SPONSOR THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS,
SUPPORT AND WE'D ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE ABOUT THE BILL, BUT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT PROTECTING
POLICYHOLDER INTERESTS FOR
THOSE, CUSTOMERS WHO BUY OUR
INSURANCE PRODUCT AND HELP
THEMSELVES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
PREPARE FOR, DAMAGING
EARTHQUAKES. THANK YOU. HOW
ABOUT YOURSELF? YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU FOR
HEARING OUR BILL. AND WE'RE JUST
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I'M LOOKING
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC THAT
WISHES TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL MAY COME UP TO THE
TO THE LECTERN. THANK YOU. YOU,
DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
NOW? I'LL GO TO THE OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY WISHING TO OPPOSE THE
BILL. OKAY. THANK YOU. I WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO THE MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS? OKAY. SEEING NO
INTEREST. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, I
WILL JUST TURN IT OVER FOR
CLOSING WITH THAT SAID, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL NOW CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. OH, WAIT. I THINK IT
WAS MR. CORTEZ. YES MOVED BY MR.
CORTEZ, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL
1505 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO JUDICIARY. RUBIO. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. NILO. AYE. MILO. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO GIL.
AYE. CABRERA. CORTEZ. CORTEZ
AYE. DODD. DODD. AYE. OKOBO
OKOBO. AYE. THE MEASURE HAS SIX
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND IF
ANYBODY IS LISTENING, THOSE
MEMBERS THAT ARE ABSENT, WE ARE
GETTING READY TO CLOSE, PLEASE
MAKE YOUR WAY HERE. THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
SO I BELIEVE WE'RE MISSING A
SENATOR CABALLERO. OKAY. THANK
YOU.
THE SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WILL TAKE A BRIEF RECESS, AND
WE'LL COME BACK. YEAH.
THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER, FROM RECESS, AND WE HAVE
TWO, BILLS UP, WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ROLL FIRST ON BILL AB
2743. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB 2743 BY PACHECO
. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY. RUBIO. AYE. NILO AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. CABRERA.
CABRERA AYE. CORTEZ. Â. AYE.
DODD AYE. OKOBOJI I SEVEN ZERO.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN ZERO. THE
BILL PASSES, NOW I HAVE
SOMETHING REALLY QUICK. HE HAD
ON ON HIS BILL.
I'M SORRY. CAN YOU REPEAT THE
MOTION AND. AND THE VOTE? ON,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ'S
BILL, NUMBER IS 1505 AB 1505 BY
RODRIGUEZ. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. RUBIO.
AYE. NILO. AYE ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DODD AYE. OKOBOJI.
AYE THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH, WE WANT
TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS THAT
SHOWED UP AND, THOSE THAT, CAME
TO VISIT AT THIS POINT, THE
COMMITTEE HEARING IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.